last time there were two epic finale so
close together which 2004 that was
Fraser and friends they were a week
apart two of my favorite shows and
speaking of friends well it's one of the
many TV shows that eg was so lucky to be
on the set off for the final seasons as
we break down TV's biggest finales of
all time okay should we get some coffee
sure where et was there as Ross and
Rachel finally figured it out but the
closing of Central Perk was nothing
compared to what we saw when cheers
issued a last call after Sam locked up
Boston hosted a heck of a finale party
in 1993 the tough part about all of this
is how are we gonna find an excuse to
get together again after 11 seasons and
31 Emmys Cheers spin-off Frasier signed
off with lots of hugs and et was behind
the scenes of the highest-rated series
finale ever mash we got a cutaway Alan
Alda directed as 106 million people
tuned in what we're out in the year 76
million watched the Seinfeld finale but
most didn't like it we had this
conversation before you think lost
ending has been called by some the
dumbest ending ever The Sopranos and Mad
Men's vague endings resulted in mixed
feelings
while Sex in the City had a send-off
that wasn't did you want to come on
Carrie got a happy ending and we got to
spin-off movies what is considered the
best series finale of all time while
that would go to Newhart and the show
the surprise twist you won't believe the
dream I just had
Bob Newhart waking up next to his first
sitcom wife Suzanne Pleshette ending is
1980 sitcom no more Japanese food before
you go to bed
[Music]